with the coveted numbers turning grim
2600 to 2800 daily deaths on wednesday
thursday and friday
the media are again covering a fierce
debate over locking down businesses and
things got
pretty heated between cnbc's rick
santelli and andrew ross sorkin
the difference between a big box
retailer hold on
the difference between a big box
retailer and a restaurant
or frankly even a church are
so different it's unbelievable i live in
an area where there's a lot of
restaurants
that have fought back and they don't
have any problems and they're open okay
you don't have to believe it but let me
just say this you're doing a disservice
to the viewer
because the viewers need to understand
you're doing a discussion
you are
well kane uh rick santelli is a
conservative who's on-air iran helped
launch the tea party andrew
sorkin is a more liberal new york times
business columnist so settle this
who was doing a disservice to voters
well i mean i take no um pleasure in
this nor do i find this anything
personal but andrew ross sorkin is doing
a disservice to the viewers because
he is condescendingly smugly telling us
exactly how it is and not backing it up
i don't understand
how it is a big box retailer so clearly
different than a church or a small
business
why is it that a big box retailer should
be open while small businesses shut down
and i'm not going to
be satisfied with a simple intonation of
it's science
i don't understand how is that science
and you repeating it over and over isn't
an explanation
it's just you looking down your nose at
us you know that's the thing howie that
i really
get fired up about i've been in the
media for quite some time and i've been
at several media institutions and it is
rife with condescension it is rife with
smugness and elitism towards people out
there across the country and i think
it's
i think it's embodied in that clip right
there really sitting there going you
know corporations
they're the ones that can do this right
but you at home you individuals you
small businesses
follow the science you must shut down
it's just absolutely condescending and i
don't think it's appropriate anymore
when you're speaking from a big pulpit
on that point condescension is a big
reason where a lot of why a lot of
people
really distrust or resent the media
kristen salter sanderson does public
opinion tend to be
uh reduced to an either or situation
where we talk about whether it's big box
retailers
versus schools versus churches
versus local restaurants or do the media
tend to reduce these questions to black
and why because it makes for better
television
well what i see in public opinion is
that by and large americans across the
political spectrum
want to make smart personal choices for
themselves the problem is that a lot of
the experts that they've been hearing
from over the last year
there have been many mixed messages
whether it ranged from early in the
pandemic being told don't wear masks
to them being told no no wear math or
being told don't congregate with lots of
people
but then suddenly public health experts
sort of waving some of that away during
the protests over the summer
the reality is that the virus doesn't
care how virtuous your cause is all it
cares is how close are you in proximity
to other people who can be a host for
the virus
and i think that lack of credibility
paired with many politicians
who have been for instance caught
lecturing their city don't get together
don't see your family for thanksgiving
while traveling to cabo closing down
restaurants that have invested a lot in
trying to create
outdoor dining saying nope not even
outdoor dining anymore
when just recently they were dining at
high-end restaurants in california
um plenty of instances of hypocrisy from
many of our leaders and that's why
people
who want to do the right thing feel a
little bit lost as to what that is right
now
right and those are democratic mayors
and governors leslie marshall uh most of
california starting today
under a stay at home order los angeles
county where you are took the lead
do you think the media debate reflects
the difficulty of these decisions about
restrictions and curfews in which
businesses or other institutions should
be able to remain open
absolutely i know you guys get sick of
hearing it my husband came home
yesterday
and he really he looked like he had been
beaten up
and he has been on er call for seven
days straight and this is what he told
me and i quote
i have never seen it like this before we
are running out of beds in the icu
they are building tents in the parking
lot and i have never seen so many
people code in my life i have partners
and
staff who are positive it just doesn't
stop
and this this is what i'm hearing a
neighbor of mine he's an er doctor
he said every other day i think i have
covid people don't understand
whether it's a politician or the media
the the science is so fluid on this
howie because this is so new
doctors are learning and this is why
it's okay this is why it's so
challenging
so challenging for me well i've got 20
seconds in that er
and any and and the reason we have a
lockdown
is not political it is because there are
people who are not complying with social
distancing
and there are people that are not
complying with not gathering or people
not complying with we're all concerned
about
that's hurting our health let me get
well let me get well in for a final
thought for in 20 seconds i'd love to
answer the question you asked leslie is
there is there a tie between
politicians who are hypocritical in the
media attitude towards this yes it is
that elitism
it's rules for the little people but not
for me it is absolutely a
view from a lockstep one point of view
with inside the halls of most media
companies
that says listen to me preach don't
worry about what i practice
the same as politicians yeah
hypocrisy is pretty thick all right
thank you all panel